foreign
[Music]
did you know what was gonna happen to my
brother when you stuck him with this
world destroying thing
called the Scarab
I had no idea it would activate it has
to choose you
so how do we get it to unchoose me
[Music]
acquired who said that distance
no and when we get in mode
threat eliminated
I think the government is gonna do when
they figure out that some kid has this
military attack
with the power of this
committee
oh he's pissed
listen to me
you got the wrong guys
the world is a place to protect I have
an Arsenal at my disposal
whatever you can imagine
yeah that's more like it
low you feel for your family makes you
weak you're wrong that's what makes me
strong
oh I forgot how bad it looks foreign
excuse me Mr Reyes
he finished scraping the gum off that
lounge or what all right
everything right now feels so Out Of
Reach you always land on your feet bro
you're hymen
I just wanna rap Johnny
life but do not open it you went in to
get us jobs and all you brought back was
the hamburger
okay I don't think it's a burger you
haven't looked
what the hell is that
[Applause]
okay
oh
re-entry systems ready
it's some kind of world destroying
weapons it's designed to protect the
toast
sometimes it does what you want and
sometimes it doesn't
I I think I cut a bus in half
Scarab chose you but it belongs to me
hello you feel for your family
makes you weak
[Music]
the universe has sent you a gift and you
have to figure out what you're going to
do with it
whatever you can imagine
I can create
[Music]
ah
my eyes choice
it's like Batman stuff Batman's a
fascist
[Music]